[Music]
all right people of the internet I'm
Dave ruin this is the Ruben report it's
Friday which it means it's time for
another Friday Roundtable
Extravaganza and joining me today is the
founder of new discourses and the author
of the Marx ification of Education James
Lindsay and also joining me is the vice
president of strategy risks and
co-founder of ideas Beyond borders
Melissa Chen James Melissa I feel like
we're getting the the band back together
how are you guys we're good I'm good
hello fellow uh conceptual penus
HS so there is a specific reason that I
wanted to have you guys on this week uh
because obviously the last 10 days have
been uh pretty tough all around
regardless of what your politics are and
we've seen sort of just the level of
craziness that we've all been dealing
with for years is kind of exploding into
every facet of society in culture and
politics and everything else but the two
of you I consider uh two of the people
that were kind of on the front end of
warning about what woke was going to
become we used to all call it the
regressive left and we were fighting
identity politics and all of that and
people were calling us Nazis who
suddenly now they seem to actually be
Nazis or at least aligning themselves
with modern Nazis so I thought you guys
would be perfect to have on today not to
really go into the nitty-gritty of what
missile was shot from where and what was
destroyed and this and that we all know
about all that but to kind of go back in
time a little bit and talk about how
woke uh ended up becoming basically a a
Hamas front so that's what we're going
to do today before we get to it I want
to talk to you guys about Birch gold you
guys know that Congress once again
allowed itself to be pushed into
appeasing the administration and raising
the debt ceiling for the 79th time
Paving the way for continued Reckless
spending and further devaluation of the
dollar well as our national debt
continues Skyrocket how are you
protecting your savings Times Like These
are a great reminder to to diversify a
portion of your gold of your savings
into gold how about that and you can do
that with the help of Birch gold here's
the easiest way guys Birch gold will
help you convert an existing Ira or 401K
into an IRA in Gold you don't pay a
penny out of pocket and as bricks that's
Brazil Russia India China and South
Africa band together against the dollar
more central banks are diversifying and
you're not going to believe it but
they're buying gold follow their lead
visit birchgold.com dve for your free
info kit on gold there's no obligation
just information they've got an A+
rating with the Better Business Bureau
and thousands of happy customers visit
birchgold.com dve and now back to me
okay so as I said I want to just jump
into a time machine today back up into a
little bit of how we kind of got here so
I thought this would be a nice video to
start with uh this is Democrat former
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelos
back in
2014 saying that Hamas is a humanitarian
organization war is a is is a deadly
thing and I have many Palestinians who
live in my district and I'm hearing from
them regularly about how their families
are affected who live in the region it's
a terrible thing but let me just say
that any missile that comes from
someplace has a return address and if
Israel is responding to that address uh
uh then
such a shame that the Palestinians are
using uh a rumor to be using children
and families as shields for their for
their missiles uh should we all try to
you first of all avoid conflict the
Hamas initiated this so again this this
has to be something where we try to have
the two-state solution that we have to
support we have to support aboss and his
role as leader there we have to support
Iron Dome to protect the Israelis from
the missiles we have to support the
Palestinians and what they need and we
have to confer with the qataris who have
told me over and over again that Hamas
is a humanitarian organization maybe
they could use their influence uh to um
uh to think terrorist organization
though crack to you yeah um I we've had
that
discussion guys I thought this was the
perfect clip to start with because we're
seeing so many people usually Democrats
and mainstream media New York Times CNN
ET Etc definitely MSNBC just repeat
talking points that line there at the
end well she talked to the qataris and
the qataris said that Hamas was a
humanitarian organization now remember
this is this is nine years ago I want to
reference one other thing before you
guys jump in she also mentions AOSS now
she's talking about Palestinian
Authority president mmud abas who has
not had elections in about 20 years or
so uh and she's saying we have to help
him well just this morning just
literally just this morning uh the
Palestinian Authority released an
official doent that they're sending to
all the mosques in the West Bank uh and
it calls actually for the direct
incitement to murder of Jews not just
those pesky settlers or Israelis and
they quote the Quran in it we're showing
the image right now right so I can't
read all the Arabic I'm a little behind
on my Arabic studies but uh you're going
to have to take my word for it or you
can check on Twitter for a full
translation of the whole thing uh James
let me start with you on this um this
this sort of collapse that we've seen of
the Democrat Party the the abandonment
of liberalism and the running of cover
for a lot of the bad guys I take it
you're not very surprised by any of it I
am completely not surprised completely
not surprised I mean if anybody's been
actually paying attention to the
rhetoric not just from now I have to
confess like you don't speak Arabic I
don't speak drunk very well anymore I
left college so she was pretty Cent
there follow yeah back in the day though
she was way more cogent yeah so um as it
turns out anybody who's been paying
attention to what they've been saying
what they've been writing could have
seen the writing on the wall for example
a lot of people realize that the
Democrats and the left in general have
been kind of enthrall to this character
named Angela Davis who is kind of a
domestic terrorist here in the US openly
communist this kind of stuff and she
said that she was radicalized first when
she was at UCLA underneath or UCSD one
or the other underneath Herbert maruza
the most famous of the neo-marxists uh
and then she said she was radicalized
the second time when when she went to
Palestine and so there's been this
palestin she's written books books about
this there's been this Palestinian uh
kind of leftist Alliance running for a
very very long time it's been an
undercurrent in the left for this entire
time I was just in George Floyd Square
about a week ago and guess what there's
a mural of Angela Davis what a big
surprise this is the current of the left
and so if if you studied ma as I've
unfortunately had the the displeasure of
doing um ma said that what he did in the
1940s was he used his formula his famous
formula of unity criticism Unity to
first concentrate power in the Communist
party and then use that concentrated
power to overthrow China in 1949 and
this is exactly what I think we've seen
progress over the past maybe 15 years
we've watched the very radical Fringe
within the Democrats consolidate power
in the Democratic party and Lurch it
into this extremism and so as I keep
saying on Twitter right now this is the
house that woke built yeah Melissa you
know again I started with that from 2014
because if you listen to the begin
beginning portion she's kind of making
sense you have to respond when Rockets
are shot at you and you know it's a damn
shame they put kids with these rockets
and everything else and then it slips
into just repeating what the qaris want
which goes to my theory that the the
Democrats and and the failure of the
Liberals unfortunately and I think all
three of us at one time at least
considered ourselves liberals or or are
old schooled liberals not that it's
worth explaining that much further at
this point um but do you see any
mechanism within the Democrat Party or
within the good liberals that still
remain to push back on some of what
we're seeing right
now yeah I think that's the question now
I've seen headlines has Hamas killed
woke you're starting to see a bit of a
realization especially among like
leftist Jews who are progressive but are
suddenly realizing wait a minute I
marched with you you know for black Liv
matters but when it came to the you know
slaughtering of of Jews in the kutas and
uh near the border of
Gaza they they threw them out of the bus
right their own movement has thrown them
out of the bus and it's we've seen far
too many progressives completely
refusing to condemn the atrocities that
Hamas has uh has conducted we've seen
them even sitting professors who said
they found it um exhilarating I think
that was the word that a Cornell
professor used cathartic to see to see
this I mean they're openly the they're
celebrating open season on Jews and it's
it's out on the streets in so many major
cities in London in Sydney and New York
um and the reason for this is that
wokeness has kind of given um people a
reason to treat any kind of oppressed
group as if they're just completely
Beyond criticism right so you can't even
bring yourself to criticize a a group
that is so clearly so clear clearly just
evil personify and and I think what you
saw in pel's rhetoric there is just it's
just another kind of inclination to to
see the good in in these marginalized
group and and not take them for its word
I mean Hamas is quite clearly just Isis
reincarnate and I you know one of the
the differences between when Isis was
was kind of at its peak in 2014
2015 I didn't see the left like open so
openly shill for ises like there was
they may have denied their motivations
but what five were're like seven years
from there from from 2015 and and now
you're starting to see it's it's gotten
this is kind of like the the climax of
of woke like people openly celebrating
what Hamas has done yeah so I want to
connect that to a video from 2021 and
it's sort of of you're both referencing
why this is going to make sense when you
hear it now as crazy as it sounds this
is the leader of Hamas back in 2021 at
the height of our summer of love and the
George Floyd riots and everything else
and watch how on English television he's
trying to connect George Floyd to the
plight of the
Palestinians FL
gey wait I'm sorry I'm actually a little
confused for a moment do were they
reading the subtitles there oh so you
may not have seen the subtitles on that
video but in essence as I laid it out he
was saying that what's happening in
America with George Floyd is exactly
what's happening in quote unquote
Palestine with uh with the Palestinians
so I want to show you one other thing
right now uh well actually James let me
let me have you comment on that the way
they can you explain a little bit about
the way they connect these perceived
oppressed groups I mean all forms of
Oppression are forms of Oppression by
dominant groups that's what the the
doctrine of intersectionality is about
it was a way to weld together all of the
various claims to oppression in the
world all of the all of the groups that
they wanted to be able to to to Forge
into what they call solidarity which
means that you agree with these people
you back these people up regardless of
of the details they actually say that
that's what it means and it's not a
surprise that black lives matter called
itself a decolonization movement what's
happening uh from Hamas they call a
decolonization movement they say they're
driving out the s s settler colonialists
in Israel it's the same exact thing and
the The Playbook was written by a
radical who is considered quote dynamite
in print by anti
and that that that radical's name is is
France Fannon he was uh writing in the
50s and in the 60s in ' 61 he published
his most famous book which is The
Wretched of the earth if you actually
read woke stuff you'll see them appeal
by name to The Wretched of the Earth all
the time they say it as a group of
people which would be Palestinians which
would be the capital B blacks that black
lives matter allegedly represented that
would be trans these are all people that
are in solidarity and what
decolonization is framed as in that book
the first chapter is called concerning
violence France Fannon writes in the
first sentence that whatever you want to
call it the process of decolonization is
always violent and then this got
summarized in the forward which was the
most influential to the west by John
Paul SRA who is a you know lunatic
Marxist existentialist French dirt bag
and frankly and it was very popular it
turns out in the Middle East in the
intellectual currents that surrounded
the Palestinian uh in Hamas rise it this
is this is
also been covered pretty well it turns
out that what John Paul SRA said is that
that these people are not just justified
in taking back land and and even mental
space through violence it's exactly how
they remake themselves as human beings
and so what SRA describes to summarize
Fannon is that decolonization is a
ritual through murder to remake man as
he should be and uh this is the current
that runs through black lives matter
it's the current that runs through the
violence we see from the trans activists
it's the exact same current that's
captured the Democratic party and and
the left at large and this is the same
violence that we see from the statement
that came out this morning from the
Palestinian Authority it's the same
thing we see on the streets by the way
you said you know Sydney and London and
New York Melissa I saw the protest in
Omaha Nebraska the other day with my own
eyes um at the crossroads spot down
there in Downtown Omaha so it's
everywhere and this is this is woke this
is what we have been nourishing in our
universities this is what we we've been
feeding and pumping into our
institutions this is what we've been
enabling through unfettered immigration
and now uh we have we've we've swn the
storm and we're going to reap the
Whirlwind is I think where we're at
Melissa before I have you jump in I want
to I want to show people the
direct connection between woke ideas in
schools that that James is talking about
and then how these people end up quite
literally in our government often
handling things as important as uh
immigration check this out from the
daily wire the US immigration
enforcement agency hired a former
spokeswoman for the Palestinian Liber
Liberation Organization the PLO and put
her in a position to determine who gets
to come into the country as an immigrant
or Asylum Seeker now the Department of
Homeland Security Officer is repeatedly
posting pictures of Hamas terrorist
terrorists parachuting in with guns and
writing F Israel and any Jew who
supports Israel a daily wire investig
ation found Nua Ali worked in 2016 and
2017 as a public affairs officer for the
palestini Palestinian delegation to the
US which according to its own website
served as the PLO office in DC that
office was expelled from the country uh
by the Trump Administration but Ali
landed on her feet according to a
screenshot of her LinkedIn profile
securing a job at DHS as an asylum
officer where she was tasked with
applying immigration laws and regul to
Asylum applications this January she
moved over to being an adjudication
officer for the US citizenship and
Immigration Services people with that
job according to the agency analyze new
or amended legislation and policy
prepare written reports and findings and
review and make determinations on cases
for immigration benefits Melissa this is
particularly important because suddenly
Jamal Bowman AOC Rashida Talib they're
saying that we should take in a million
Gins and you think that maybe we don't
have the best of the best vetting these
people or I guess a more cynical version
would be that we actually have enemies
within that are glad to let some bad
people in yeah absolutely I you know I I
think it's we deserve to find out what
happened there how on Earth did the the
fox you know get in charge of of the
chicken Coupe um want to jump back a
little bit on on the uh connecting all
that dots and and why this particular
story should alarm us all it's that you
know when when I saw these protests uh
in in New York City in Times Square
there were signs and that that said
resistance is not terrorism and that
word was very very prevalent during the
the the four years of the Trump administ
you heard resistance all the time um
it's also what antifa and BLM thought
they were doing um they under the banner
of resistance they Justified burning
they Justified looting
um you know beating up conservative
journalists to a pulp you can justify so
much under the banner resistance and
that's how people are justifying now
what Hamas is doing as well and in the
mindset of these people you know where
you have this bundle of ideas that kind
of get like swallowed wholesale
everywhere everything from you know
decolonization to anti-racism and
everything and by the way decolonization
it's very clear that this radical
rhetoric with zero limiting principles
was not nearly just a call to rid
curricula of Mozart and Shakespeare uh
it turns out and and I think you know
the left is waking up to that that it's
far far far more Sinister um and and so
for someone like nja is that her name
who is working for the
DHS I I I don't know the exact
pronunciation but hopefully we don't
know need to know her name after this by
the way I should note that she's on
leave as of yesterday so there is I
guess a bit of a silver lining here good
but you can imagine that somebody with
that kind of mindset of resistance what
they would be willing to do in that
capacity in order to achieve their
political goals and that's what makes
them dangerous James I want to ask you
one other thing on this before we get to
the next segment which is how do how is
it do you think or do you know or is
someone doing some research on this that
they can just flip the switch of when
they want protest so for example we had
the year of protests against Trump and
for BLM and antifa and they were you
know diverse and peaceful Pro protests
that were burning down buildings and
destroying every Pep Boys and Target
then it disappears when we get two years
of Biden but then it's basically like
overnight they can have high school kids
in San Francisco rampaging through the
schools screaming Free Palestine these
kids have no idea what they're saying
but how is the switch actually flip that
ignites all of these kids like is this
coordination on freaking I don't know I
don't know what is this Tik Tok like
what is this well I mean they do they do
identify influencers and and centers of
influence of that kind I think that's
the actual term in the older literature
is centers of influence so in the media
they they ramp up the the messaging on
social media in particular they ramp up
the messaging to get the younger people
but uh Within These high schools they
keep putting out the narrative that this
is student-led protest student L
activism student L activity but in fact
in almost every case I have a researcher
that works for parents defending
education that's dug into this and I'm
friends with and he says in almost every
case you can pull it back to some Pro uh
left NGO that is is is telling them it's
time to flip the switch that's putting a
few of the kids who are going to go
March out and start the thing and then
it's just just like with what we saw
with black lives matter you get a few
agitators to start to take a allegedly
peaceful protest and turn it crazy and
the whole thing kind of catches fire
because that energy is already there and
people are already kind of primed to do
it and they're they're already fed with
the woke ideology I'll do another
connect the dots around you know Melissa
did the word resistance look at the word
in the middle of of PLO Liberation what
did Ma call his army the people's
Liberation Army Herbert maruza who I
mentioned earlier his one of his most
influential pieces of writing from 1969
was an essay on Liberation shavara LED
Liberation armies black lives matter
claimed that they were working for
Liberation the trans rights activists
claimed that they're working for
Liberation Liberation is a communist
code word and so what you're actually
seeing is probably something extremely
coordinated that's being fed largely
through these different NOS but also
pressed through the compliant and
complicit media and they can turn on the
switch because the people that they need
to go do these protests these activities
these demonstrations are already primed
that once it starts to just join in it's
the right thing to do uh they're afraid
that they'll be ostra ostracized by
their friends if they don't take part
you you we saw the scene in Black lives
matter where there was the one girl who
even said she agreed with black lives
matter who was surrounded by you know
hundred some odd people with their fists
raised in her face telling her to raise
her fist and she didn't because it felt
compelled that became an iconic image
there's this sense that you'll be left
out ostracized lonely shamed bullied by
your friends lose your friends group for
standing up and not participating in
these things so it's very easy to get
momentum going if you just have a small
number of agitators willing to go out
and do this and they can be activated by
both media but also like my friend has
dug up you know nonprofit uh activation
activities right and any of us can think
back to high school on the pressure
you're on from friends and when you talk
about that as our friend Abigail shrier
writes the social contagion that leads
to all of these girls thinking they're
boys it's the same type of social
contagion that leads to them chanting
for for genocide basically I want to
move on and talk a little bit about how
this is sort of hitting us also from a a
cultural perspective not just education
and not just our ridiculous politicians
but real quick guys let me talk to you
about satellite phone store uh you know
that fires hurricanes and tornadoes can
happen almost anywhere and your cell
phone could go down as a result but not
satellite phone satellite phones will
always work because you are carrying
your personal cell tower with you
everywhere or anywhere you want to go on
Earth anyone who has a satellite phone
in the affected areas of Hawaii the
Nevada desert Burning Man for example
has a way to communicate with friends
family and Emergency Services prepare
prepare for the unexpected the most
secure way to communicate is from a
satellite phone to satellite phone you
can't be tracked and no one can listen
in on your calls even the US military
uses sat at it phone for secured
communication so here's a deal for you
visit
sat23 or call
866321 1884 and use promo code Dave 50
to wave the $50 activation fee the
service is only applicable to those in
the USA again just visit sat23 and use
promo code day 50 to wave the $50
activation fee or call 866 3201
1884 and now back to us all right so I
want to show a little bit of how all of
this wokeness that leads to this bizarre
guilt and an incapacitated group of
people who seemingly can't step up
against a bunch of 15-year-olds who
don't know what they're protesting about
uh how it's been pushed on us virtually
at every level there is a Girl by the
name of Sarah REO uh she is she's I
suppose big on Twitter as one of these
anti-racist people although everything
that she writes out is seemingly racist
she's she considers herself an American
radical political activist so of course
she got a TV show uh the TV show is
called race to dinner and yes it's as
bad as you think take a look you
actually marget you didn't say yours
what your racist thing thing that you've
done thought about or
done you have something inside of you
that's not quite like that's racist so
you must have you must have examples in
your own life I also work in
environmental engineering I have
absolutely no people of color or minimal
people of color possibly the exclusion
being slightly
Hispanic s doesn't like her
attitudes I can say a rasist thing
you've done because it just happened
when you just talked to me the way you
just did this is how white women talk to
us all the time these are
microaggressions when I say the exact
same thing to my white girlfriend who
says the same exact thing I don't care
if you talk to everybody like that the
way you just spoke to me was straight up
white supremacy you just answered with
racism white supremacy is said to be
hidden in innocuous phrases and banile
behavior the smallest things could be
considered racist it's enough that a
person from a minority group feels
insulted
absolutely sounding terribly white I
don't know that I was all that racist to
start with but I also would be
more aware or hyper aware of my thoughts
or reactions to
circumstances that would be
racist I have so many jokes and so many
comments that I wrote down I honestly
don't know where to start other than the
British guy who was doing the voice over
in honor of racism shot himself in the
head because he was an old white man at
the end of recording that thing Melissa
these people are so extraordinary
pathetic extraordinarily pathetic but
again they're just grow they're just
reacting to a society that has gone
completely
wrong oh by the way they they pay her
500 $ for that she doesn't pay them to
sit there they pay her $500 for the
privilege of having a meal where someone
tells you that you're a white
supremacist yeah okay do do you notice
how smug that woman was the one who's
accusing the poor white woman of of
being racist she was so smug she was
being a bully and this whole scene to me
looks like these are are are people that
have terrible personality
that fine camouflage in the IDE ideology
like she's just using this ideology to
kind of bully this woman and to talk to
her in a way that's just you know
feeding her own narcissism it seems like
to me I mean James probably knows more
about this kind of phenomenon but but
that's just what it what it what it
seems like it it is to me that that it
just gives you a license to treat others
which with cruelty with such
viciousness am I am I right and it's
it's just evil like it's just it's James
please it's just patently evil what you
just watched just now was a ma struggle
session But the irony is that Ma had to
throw people in prison to get them put
into conditions of struggle whereas
literally you can get awful white women
signing up to pay $500 a piece to
participate in their own struggle
session but the point of the struggle
session was that you had this this uh
social group around you that was going
to help you uh want to confess to these
crimes which you also had a interrogator
who would accuse you of crimes that in
in the the phrasing from from the
Chinese that you were not able to
recognize and so the goal was to help
you learn to recognize your crimes in
this case your crimes of racism which
were invisible to you and the goal is to
bully you and to Hound you and to create
a social environment where it feels like
there's a pressure for you to want to
confess and then the second you start to
confess the next stage is to say that
your confession is not sincere enough
and you continue to twist the thumbs
scws the emotional and social thumb
screws until you get people like at the
end we saw the lady saying that she you
know she could be more aware I could
learn more about my My Invisible crimes
so what you're what's being ha what's
happening is there is there there's a
imaginary crime on contrived standards
the systemic racism microaggressions
blah blah blah CRT line and the goal is
to bully people into accepting those
contrived terms so that they can learn
to recognize how they were criminal
against the people what what the maist
called it that was learning to see from
the people's standpoint which is exactly
what we call woke now you're learning to
see things from the critical race
theorist standpoint or from the person
of color's point of view and that's
exactly what we heard from SRA R now I
will point out as far as jokes go that
the the the translation service
committed a microaggression by
misspelling her name it it spelled it
Sila instead of Sy which is kind of
hilarious um but uh what you watched is
a ma struggle session what you watched
is a form of psychological torture that
rather than having you know $4 or $5,000
worth of money going to the perpetrator
of this thing she should be held to
account under under uh laws against
torture because it is a form of
psychological torture I want to show you
one more this is this is a shorter clip
let me just throw in let me just throw
in one other shorter clip because it's
not just that these white women are
racists their mothers are racists I do
think every white person in the United
States is racist I'm a racist and my
mother I think I said it was a racist
one wonderful person wonderful lady I
mean that's a I think I think there's no
mixing up you can be a really good
person and still be
racist why what are we doing with our
lives Melissa defend white people you're
Asian that doesn't bode well for you in
this game either but you know come on
give me a little something for white
people well okay so I I that's the
question I was going to ask is is what
is driving you know given that this is a
struggle session and that they're
actually paying money to actually be a
part of this I don't really understand
what drives a normal person to want to
to submit themselves to the
psychological torture is it kind of like
these Finance Bros these like
high-flying Tech CEOs who pay Financial
dominatrix to like shame them or
something is this kind of like willingly
submitting to a
humiliation um session I I I I don't
really understand what what's going on
but you know I I think we've in a way
just created a um a moral there are that
their status to be gained by flagala
yourself it seems and when you have
these kind of moral incentives they get
rewarded based on the social hierarchy
you know if you acknowledge your racism
and you're part of this movement um you
you're going to have moral entrepreneurs
to kind of take advantage of that market
you know we've told white people that um
they they have this original sin they
have they were born with this privilege
and so kind of to redeem themselves and
to to regain their moral status in
society seems like this is what they
must do either that or you know try to
acquire some sort of um oppression
points in a way right and that's the
part where you were talking about
earlier about social contagion and you
know perhaps identifying as a sexual
minority it in some way that that's why
you have this phenomenon of like you
know queer queer white people it's like
you're not gay you're not you're just
queer so you at least have this one
oppression Point you're just annoying
usually it just means they're annoying
that's kind of how it works but actually
you're giving me a great segue there
Melissa because it's not just that you
suddenly if you're woke have to be for
you know beheading a holocaust Survivor
and calling your mother racist you also
have to be for biological men beating
women in sports here is video of a
transfemale
weightlifter also known as a dude
explaining why he should be able to beat
chicks in weightlifting what is it to be
a
woman yeah
um so I don't think it's a good question
I don't because I think people want it
to be objective and clear and there to
be clear criteria and I think that's
impossible and I think we need to accept
that and I think that's a difficult
thing to accept gender is more beautiful
and more complex than what is a man what
is a woman so who are women the people
who say they are I think is the easier
way to go about it the male body has a
bigger strength than the female body
what do you think about that the
question isn't are male bodies bigger
than female bodies but are trans women
trans female bodies bigger than CIS
female CIS women's bodies trans women
are female like actually female um
medically female legally female my
doctors treat me as any other female
driver's license passport my racing
licenses all say
female before I have you guys chime in
we've had an internal debate on the show
all week because for the last 10 days
I've cursed more on this show than at
any other time in the history of the
whole show I've called people all sorts
of names and everything else and and my
mom said to me yesterday David could you
just ease up a little bit on that stuff
so I'm actually not going to comment on
that video of that
wonderful person that you just saw there
uh James I'll allow you because I can't
control my guests obviously can you
explain anything that that person just
said I can explain pretty much all of it
gender is beautiful though it's much
more beautiful than the ugly person
saying it um who as we also I mean I see
goodlooking guys I see beautiful women
on this program I don't see it on that
but the fact it's just easy to see we
don't have to we don't have to kid
ourselves but the fact of the matter is
is that we see yet another kind of crime
that you have to learn to recognize so
you Empower that moral entrepreneurship
or moral bullying we're just talking
about it's another basis to have an
interminable number of struggle sessions
to to browbeat people you know gender is
much more complicated than sex it's in
fact you can't even really Define what
it is which means you have to appeal to
somebody like that in order to Define
what it is in other words like Kon G
Brown Jackson said when she couldn't
answer what is a woman despite being a
woman she said we need an expert to tell
us who qualifies as male and who
qualifies as female we need an expert to
guide us through life and the only
qualified experts are the people who
have the secret knowledge of what it
takes that they've adopted through queer
Theory and if you can't see it well
you're transphobic you're you know G
Dave I know you're very homophobic it's
a big problem in your life only to one
guy the guy I'm married to yeah well
thinks you're homophobic too I mean
everybody thinks you're homophobic we
all know you're homophobic because you
actually you you do crazy things like
past you don't although phobia is an
irrational fear I have a rational fear
of him you know what I mean if I don't
make the bed it's fully rational I also
have a a fully rational fear of mental
illness um as it turns out visible
mental illness as a matter of fact and
so the the fact is that what you're
seeing is another basis for another set
of struggle sessions to twist more thumb
screws on more people who are LED around
by their uh controlled empathy uh into
lunacy and Madness which becomes a
downward spiral until the next thing you
know you're chanting for whatever slogan
it is trans women or women black lives
matter you know apparently gas the Jews
um that the that the big complex throws
at you and says that you have to support
this week Melissa you're a chick what's
the deal with
that with chicks we we have failed to
gatekeep so many Concepts and this is
one of those
you know downfall of Western
Civilization things right we we've
failed to gatekeep the concept of a
woman we failed to
gatekeep racism even we've allowed them
to redefine what racism is and all these
Concepts that we've just like expanded
and and not try to assert no that is
just because you feel like a woman as
this person said in the clip doesn't
mean you're woman there there is a
meaning to that and
it's very clear what it is but for
whatever reason and you know this is
where Peter and and James have talked a
lot about this this kind of standpoint
epistemology
where everything is just what it is
because that's what you you know feel
like or it's completely subjective it
depends on on on the person talking or
or interpreting it um this is this is
the path that leads us down and on the
back of of of the room you saw the word
sport is a human right no this is not
about sport this that's a Corruption of
what this issue is this is about this is
about about women's leagues and whether
or not men deserve to be in these spaces
whether or not men deserve to be um you
know in contact with with women in
prisons and um competing in in contact
Sports where Women's skulls could get
bashed I mean the stakes are very high
hi as our friend Douglas Murray says one
day The Barbarians will be at the gate
and we will be debating what gender
pronouns to call them uh I just want to
show you guys two more Clips because I
want to connect this wider now to the to
sort of politically everything that's
happening and then James I we have to go
short here today because you where where
are you going do we even want to say it
because I know there's already going to
be a lot of protesters on there do you
want me to give you a as well we're
going to Hartford Connecticut is where
we're going we're going to we're going
to bring the fire of Truth to Hartford
Connecticut and show the people the way
you're basic Al you're going to Harford
Connecticut with moms of Liberty who are
a great organization I know the ladies
and of course they're now being called
Nazis and everything else they're
actually fighting the Nazis but uh all
right we'll we'll post some video I'm
sure of the wonderful protesters uh but
I want to connect this to The Wider
political thing at the moment uh here is
an MSNBC reporter announcing the latest
in what's going on with Trump in these
indictments that he now has a partial
gag order and we'll connect it to
everything else that we're talking about
minutes ago judge Tanya chuckin
announced from the bench that she will
impose a partial gag order on former
president Donald Trump specifically she
will prohibit all parties in the case
including Mr Trump from making or
reposting any statements publicly
targeting the special counsel his staff
the judge's staff or Court personnel and
also will prohibit statements about
potential Witnesses and the subject of
their testimony that really put in in on
Stark display The Clash here between uh
the First Amendment and Donald Trump's
ability to speak as he's running for
president Melissa the reason I wanted to
show that clip is because I think
there's a direct correlation to the
people who are behaving like Nazis now
are the ones who called everyone else
including Donald Trump a Nazi for years
thus they will clearly not stand up for
his Free Speech rights or his ability to
run for president for all the
frustrations I might have with him and
it seems pretty obvious perhaps would
get us to some of that communist ma kind
of stuff you were talking about earlier
James Melissa go ahead yeah no it's it's
the same with James me referen moms for
Liberty and moms for Liberty is you know
a parent parent group largely a
Grassroots parents organization that's
been trying to counter the influence of
CRT in in education all the way from K
12 to um to college and they were they
were considered terrorists they were
labeled as terrorists by Biden doj um
and you know this is the same faction of
people that are they seem to be
completely unable to to call Hamas what
they are which is you know terrorists it
just seems to me that the more they they
they try to you know gag Trump uh it it
just seems like this political
politically motivated actions to just
prevent him from speaking prevent him
from being able to engage in in a way
that a presidential candidate can is
only boosting his popularity like we're
we're we're seeing I I just saw the
morning consult poll um in head-to-head
with Biden in swing States like Arizona
and Georgia and and Michigan Trump is
actually leading um and so the more they
try to do this the more they try to call
somebody you
know a Nazi and white supremacist when
there clearly isn't any evidence he
becomes a martyr for for the cause and
and people start seeing that and they're
like wait a minute that's not what's
going on here and so they they react and
they say you know what you're calling my
guy this you're calling us this I mean
it was extended to all Trump trump
supporters I mean that was the whole
point about you know the the four years
of of trump it's like anyone that was
remotely that they could expand that
concentric circle of to to Tar with the
label of Nazi white supremacist bigot
they got tarred um and so we're living
in in in kind of this you know weird
moral myopia now where the very people
who are acting like
Nazis targeting the Jews outright
calling and enjoying the idea of ethnic
cleansing and and you know they're
they're they're
escaping you you gave me another great
segue because I got one more clip for
you and then James I'll let you take us
out on this uh this is from The View and
it was a miracle because earlier in the
week I played a clip of the view and I
and I actually had to give some of them
credit for kind of getting this thing
right Joy and Anna aaro and some of them
were kind of right obviously Sunny
hustin is is complete lunatic uh but
Rachel mattow Rachel mattow who has lied
about everything over the last couple
years Trump being a Nazi she lied about
coid vaccines election interference I
mean she has lied about everything watch
what she does here this is exactly what
you just laid out Melissa they accuse
you of doing everything they are doing
or have done check this out the
Republican party right now has to make a
decision and it's their decision to make
we have party processes for a reason but
ultimately if you listen to what Trump
is saying you don't just sort of regard
him as a um as a spectacle but you
listen to what he's saying yeah he's
basically portraying a future for
America if he is put back in the White
House in which we don't have another
election after that because the
elections are all rigged that the
Democratic process can't be trusted that
Congress should just work for him the
justice department should just work for
him that's a strongman form of
government that's not he canceled the
news like the news are done that he
wants to put MSNBC on trial for treason
so that he can execute us I mean this is
and he will put Rudy Giuliani on the
Supreme Court if he makes it that long
sure yeah I mean it is that the
Republican party is if they're going to
elevate somebody like that to represent
their party in a in a general election
not only do we have a 50-50 shot of him
being back in the White House any major
party nominee has a 50 party a 50% shot
but the Republican party will have to
reckon with that for the till the end of
time in terms of what they did to this
country wow everything she said I mean
she spent four years claiming that Trump
was an illegitimate president all of the
coid stuff everything else by the way I
think Rudy actually would be quite a
good Supreme Court Judge I don't think
anyone's really well I can't say anyone
I certainly don't think uh that his uh
legal mind uh is not worthy of that uh
James I surpr I suspect again this
doesn't surprise you the behavior this
is it it's baked into their ideology
right yeah well the iron law of
projection never of woke projection
never misses the it's an iron law they
always tell you what their intentions
are it's one of the best teristics to
guess what they have up their sleeve and
Rachel mattow should have just scared
the crap out of virtually everybody in
the country that understands that
they're telling you what their plans are
when they project them onto their enemy
but what we were watching here I can
connect all this back to Mao again what
we just saw with Trump with the gag
order um Mao said in 1957 he gave a
speech called on the correct handling of
contradictions among the people he
defined the people and the enemies of
the people said we have to start there
the people he said explicitly are those
that support the building of socialism
so in other words his movement would be
woke today everything that goes with it
the enemies of the people are everybody
who doesn't support that there would be
Donald Trump today for one example and
what he says is that the dictatorship of
the people that he was establishing
which is a democratic process apparently
is going to he called it Democratic
centralism is going to to to use the the
dictatorship the power of the
dictatorship on the enemy of the people
and he specifically says that the things
that it will do is revoke for a time
their right to speak and the right to
vote and so he explicitly says that
there will be censorship and
disenfranchisement this whole concept
gets taken up I mentioned maruza earlier
we can't not mention maruza again
because in 1965 he writes an essay
titled an essay on Liber sorry the the
titled repressive tolerance which gets
put in a book called A critique of pure
tolerance and inpressive tolerance the
thesis statement explicit near the end
of the essay the thesis statement of the
essay itself is that movements from the
left must be extended tolerance and
movements from the right must have
tolerance withdrawn from them and he
again mentions censorship he's something
he calls pre-censorship and lots of
other uh forms of disenfranchising
people on movements from the right and
so what we're seeing is ma come to
America by means of the neo-marxist or
critical Marxist movement as into
identity politics it's silencing people
like Trump it's fully on on display with
all of the movements we talked about
whether it's BLM whether it's a trans
women in sports whether it's uh this
crazy stuff from Hamas and the support
that we're seeing from every woke
University and every major city and
Democratic politicians uh what we're
seeing is is Mau ISM having come to
America and taking a very hideous form
that I think people are fortunately
starting to wake up to now that it's
gotten quite as ugly as it has but even
the gagging of trump falls into into the
exact same mold um and we will we should
expect that what Rachel matow just said
everything is exactly she she did a
gigantic confession about everything
that they plan to bring from their side
if we are uh ineffective in in standing
up to stop them well Melissa now that
James has freaked everyone out before
the weekend uh I ask you to end us on a
positive note somehow Give me the give
me the Silver Lining I think there's
partly a silver lining related to some
of the lefties finally coming around as
you referenced earlier but but is there
anything else that we can look at right
now uh that might give us a little hope
in the midst of this yes I it looks like
you know donors have been pulling their
funding from Harvard and upen and all
these endowments of big universities um
that were not clear on on denouncing and
it was a very low bar right all you have
to do is just kind of denounce himas
like you can still support the
Palestinian cause if you want it to
still kind of do both sides but at least
in now Hamas like that was such a low
bar that our presidents couldn't even do
and and the student groups that had all
signed these letters it seems like
there's a lot of backpedaling now
because firms won't hire them and so
we're starting to see backlash Corporate
America billionaires you know investor
types um so I I think people have woken
up um let let's see you know how um
whether this continues whether or not
there's more of a Snowball Effect uh
like what what other what other domains
in American society are going to be are
are going to be affected by by this well
I thank you guys I'm proud to be in this
fight with you for a long time and
unfortunately this fight a ain't going
anywhere so we will do this again uh
James I wish you good luck with the
gender queer two spirit Hamas supporters
uh today so bon voyage Melissa I'll see
you soon and for everybody else we've
got a postgame show in about 37 seconds
at Ruben report. locals.com that was my
impression of the British guy who shot
himself after the thing okay see you
[Music]
everybody